Let's learn about lions.
Often called the "king of beasts," lions are unique among the species of the cat family...
...for more than one reason.
Adult male lions are the only cats to have manes.
In addition, lions are the only cats to live in groups.
These close family groups are called prides.
Lions are mammals, which means they are warm-blooded,...
...covered in fur, and they feed their babies milk.
Lions are also carnivores, which means that they eat meat.
Lions are at the top of the food chain in the habitats where they live.
Although they are apex predators,...
...meaning that aside from humans, no other animals prey on lions,...
...lions are also scavengers.
They get about half of their food by scavenging,...
...and will eat both animals that have died naturally...
...and kills they can steal from other predators like leopards, cheetahs, and hyenas.